foreign
need a pen No it isn't dead
I was taking notes
Greg's that one coming your way
great could you send the pen that way
the paper is
all right
I'll walk it away
foreign
all right guys let's get started
welcome back
uh a lot of you have been on
considerable break
and we're back now to discuss some
interim study bills we have six to
discuss today but before we get started
if you would uh please stand and join me
in the pledge
the flag is right behind me
yeah
justice for all thank you can be seated
and just as a reminder
our procedures uh
suggests that you wait to be recognized
if you want to speak and if you do speak
you push the little button in front of
you to the red light comes on and that
means that'll turn your microphone on
and then I ask that after you finish
speaking you push it again to turn the
microphone off
otherwise what you say as a reminder
goes out over the world wide web
and is noted by
by our competitors in China and Russia
uh today our agenda is to uh
to speak to the
uh six interim study bills that we uh
put out in uh in the in last year's
legislative session uh and we have
one of two recommendations for each
uh each bill one is to recommend it for
future legislation
or not to recommend it a future
legislation which will mean that the
bill will die
here
when we write
the the committee reports
sometimes known as blurbs but we'll
we'll we'll talk about committee reports
those reports are a little different
than normal and that normally the
reports are written
in a sort of partisan way by the by the
writer uh this these reports
there's only one report there's not a a
minority and a majority with one report
and and uh it should include the
discussion or any discussion from both
sides of the aisle it should not just
include one point of view
uh and today we have uh we'll welcome uh
representative Smith from the from the
speaker's office and representative
plett also uh will be substituting in
for McBride and Air
and I don't believe the minority has any
substitutes today so uh
that that's our total
participation
Smith is behind you
and and plates over here
okay
everybody uh okay uh Jimmy have your
microphone on did you wanna
yes representative
thank you Mr chair
on any of these bills right
therefore
are we voting again on these bills
because there is no interim study to
vote on no the the vote's going to be
whether they they uh they weren't uh
future legislation continue to work them
or not that's it's
basically that's the extent of the the
vote will be taken today
thank you
okay so the way we're going to start is
going to be a little different
um
uh some of the folks uh who haven't been
in session here since last spring uh may
have
forgotten a little bit about what we
were talking about of interim study and
everything so what we're going to do is
I'm going to take a break for 15 minutes
uh to to reconvene at 25 past the hour
uh and that'll give each caucus a chance
to privately discuss
the six bills in front of us and any
particular action or uh point of view
that they may want to take so if I could
ask Jim if you could take your group
elsewhere we'll go and uh
thank you Mr I think we'll just go
across the hall hopefully nobody's
across the hall we'll see you in 15
minutes sounds good thank you please uh
turn off your
microphones if they happen to be on for
the next 15 minutes
New York
is written in a flavor that somebody's
upset locally about a particular pound
no I I I disagree it has to do with the
delegation of the powers and authorities
of members of boards and it's it's
two boards but not as a select board
well this is an important issue it
affects it affects
the entire State and they feel like it's
different people and make a motion to
kill it
foreign
no
who else puts a motion to tell them
foreign
the first time you did not think it
should pass that's why you voted in from
study
session is on the bills since nothing
has transpired between now and then
it's easy to say not recommended for
future legislation new information and a
case has to be built for any of these
bills to say yeah we're going to
recommend it complete legislative that's
that's the way it should be approaching
so I mean if nothing has gone on
and you didn't want to pass it the last
time of someone who wants to make the
yes recommended they would have to build
the case now on what's different today
as you always say
um so they we didn't
submit committees to go ahead and study
it
foreign
okay
okay we're we're back and um my
microphone is on so we are now being
recorded and uh
and publicizing these uh these comments
okay we have six interim study bills in
front of us uh
our Our obligation here is to recommend
each bill for future legislation why not
that's the the only two options we have
and there's going to be no discussion uh
and uh an amendments being offered on
any of these bills
that's the rules of the game all right
so uh
before us we the first bill is House
Bill 132 do we have a motion
yeah yes go ahead uh I recommend not
recommending House Bill 132 for
legislation prepare the legislation and
is there a second a second
okay representative Melvin is a
second
yes uh I'd like to speak to that motion
you can speak to it but there is there
is no amendment to speak no I'm not
proposing an amendment I am proposing to
say that I am going to vote against the
recommendation to not file it for
further for further uh legislation
because I actually think this is a thing
that we should be considering and I'd
like to remind everyone that
um several recent reports including one
from The mercatus Institute listed
unnecessarily large lot sizes in areas
served by water and sewer as one of the
primary drivers for housing costs I
think it's wrong for us to say that this
should not consider could be
um considered in the future
okay we we have a motion on the table to
not recommend this for additional
legislation uh in a second I'll also is
there any further discussion
seeing that and I asked the clerk to
take a vote take the role okay I'm not
recommend
hb132 Vice chairman piamati
yes
collect folks yes representative Tripp
yes representative Guthrie yeah
representative Rosales yes
representative yes
representative Melvin yes
representative Smith yes
representative power yes
representative majority no
representative Gilman
no
representative Davis no
Representative
no
Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Brian no
and chairman Dawn yes
voters uh 10 to 7.
motion passes
okay thank you uh our next uh Bill to
consider
future legislation is House Bill 1155
which is relative to uh
persons elected to a local board serving
on a second board or another board
uh and uh I'd like to ask representative
Tripp if you have a motion you'd like to
make
Mr chair I move not recommended for
future further legislation
is there a second representative Guthrie
okay
we have a motion and a second uh any
discussion
uh representative uh McBride
I'm sorry uh over there I've got three
click off your mic
thanks and representative Gallagher
thank you
all right uh you take the roll call
please
okay not recommend uh HP 1155
representative P mine yeah be Monty I'm
sorry good luck folks yes yes
representative Tripp yes weapons Guthrie
yeah representative lasalles
yes representative Platt yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Smith yes representative power
yes
representative majority yes
representative Gilman yes
representative stavis yes
Udi yes
representative van
yes
representative Gallagher
representative rung
yes
chairman Dolan yes
motion passes uh 17-0
thank you Mr clerk uh the next item
our agenda is House Bill 1172 which is
requiring composting uh at public
housing
is there a motion the representative
biamonte uh yes I have not recommended
for legislation
and a second from I second that that was
an on speaker
okay you want to do it again and I
reckon not recommended for legislation
and I second it again okay so
representative piamonte and
representative Tripp are uh I'm making
those uh motions uh is there any
discussion
yes representative Gallagher
so I'd just like to let people know that
I have actually already gone ahead and
refiled this for next year anyways so
um and yeah I'm going to be working with
the municipal Association to see if we
can improve it at all so Tom for next
time around so regardless of which way
this goes
it doesn't really matter because I'm
already refiling it okay well thank you
for your proactive uh
activity yes uh
anyone else have any comments
yes
thank you Mr chair representative here
um I am just uh going to express my
um this is a process and I was very
vocal about it during the discussion and
I wanted to work on adding municipal
waste uh management into this and I had
reached out and never heard back so I
feel like there was no process or the
typical process for an interim study was
not done and whether I vote Yes or no
it is a mute point so I just wanted to
make that statement in terms of what we
are doing today
um I know it's the chair's prerogative
to whether have the study or not having
put the time and effort coming here
in representing my constituents I feel
like I wasn't given that opportunity I
just wanted to make a statement thank
you thank you and yes representative
because representative galga I I don't
know if you would add
uh that the public housing
would have an input in this I don't know
if you've checked with them or yes I've
been trying to finish please sorry
um that it would be more so uh
it could be favorable to detrimental to
them
and I think getting their opinion uh
whether they would want something like
this may influence your legislation
uh yes I've been trying to get in touch
with my local Housing Authority but we
haven't managed to
uh set anything up yet
um I was
um as uh or rep manager who he was
saying
um yeah I was also looking forward to
doing actual interim study sessions
um on this bill over the summer too and
was hoping that if we had some we could
have
um had had the public housing
authorities come speak with us
then at one of those study sessions but
unfortunately that didn't happen so um
it's just I guess that's just something
I'll have to
keep trying to figure out for next year
okay
um I have some uh some thoughts for you
think about uh one is uh
to in addition to if you want to
consider legislation if you want to
consider speaking directly with the uh
the organization in charge of removing
trash and garbage and so forth if they
would uh if they feel within their
authority to do something like this and
the other thing is in your legislation
uh one another way to approach this is
to have legislation to approve a study
Commission uh so that you're you don't
have to rely on a committee like this to
decide to study it the the legislation
itself can say to study it so that's
just a couple of thoughts to think about
as you go forward so
so I'm looking now for for uh the clerk
to call a roll on the on the motion on
the table
okay HB 1172 not recommend uh Vice
chairman piamati yes
work votes yes representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie yeah
representative Salas yes
representative pleck yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Smith
representative power yes
representative majority no
representative Gilman no
Representative stavis no
representative Mega Pootie
no
representative van no
representative Gallagher
no
representative brung no
chairman Dolan yes
uh motion passes ten to seven
would you like us to uh wait a couple
minutes for you to come back
okay
I'm sorry I have a point of order yes
um just for uh the sake of pointing out
that there were no interim studies
that's what just happened here with
people giving testimony of
recommendations for that bill
so I just want to say there was a
purpose for an interim study thank you
uh I'm gonna
go slow here give representative LaSalle
as a chance to come back from the from
the facility uh but just heads up we're
going to discuss HP 1223 now
yes
yes you had something you wanted to add
thank you Mr chair the uh comments that
were given to representative Gallagher
on how to
change his bill going forward were
already given in testimony in this
committee when the bill was heard
had there been an interim study those
could have been fleshed out far further
and we could have been in a much
different place today than we than we
are
so
um just to note that there was no
interim study despite the fact that
several of us communicated directly with
you on several different occasions
saying that we would be more than happy
to participate in any interim studies on
any of these bills and never received a
response not even a thank you for your
email
thank you
hey we're going to take a break for uh a
minute or two to give representative
LaSalle as a chance to come back from
his uh bathroom trip
you don't think he's coming back
so uh if you would if your microphone is
on if I would ask you to turn it off and
I'll give you the cue
my microphone is back on
hopefully you can hear me well okay our
next uh Bill we're going to discuss is
House Bill
1223 which is the uh has to do with the
meeting attendance for requirements for
elected members of
of the budget committee and School Board
within your municipality
um
we're looking I'm looking for a motion
from uh representative piamonte on this
one uh yes thank you Mr Kim uh I'm
making not recommending for legislation
is there a second
from representative trip
so I'll second that
thank you we have a motion in a second
any discussion
yes representative Gallagher um so could
could I just ask someone making the
motion to speak to it um as to
um why
um
I think the uh the person who made the
motion does not want to uh respond to
that question uh
is there anything in particular you're
curious about
um I I'm just trying to remember the
details of this bill
any other uh comments discussion
seeing none has to cross take the roll
on 12 23. okay HP 1223 uh the motion is
not to recommend Vice chairman pmrt yes
click folks yes representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie yeah
representative lasalles yes
representative polite yes representative
Melvin yes representative Smith yes
representative power yes
representative majority yes
representative Gilman yes
representative Davis yes
representative yes representative van
yes
representative Gallagher
representative Brian yes
chairman Dolan yes
moshe's past is 17-0 thank you very much
our next bill before us is House Bill
which is relative to applications for
abatements and the authority to Abate
prior to the year's taxes for certain
homeowners
uh do I have a motion from
representative Piemonte uh yes okay
thank you
um not recommended for legislation
second
thank you emotion has been made in
second and that's the uh
the clerk to make the Roll Call
HB 1289 not recommended
Vice chairman piamonti
yes
click votes yes representative Tripp yes
representative Godfrey yes
representative lasalles yes
uh representative plett yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Smith yes
representative power yes represent
majority yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Stevens yes
representative yes representative van
yes representative Gallagher
uh yes
represented wrong yes
and Shannon Dolan yeah motion passed
17-0
thank you
and now last bill
today and for the session is uh house is
Senate Bill 249
which is uh prohibiting the planning and
zoning ordinances that prohibit
short-term rentals this is kind of the
double negative we're going to prohibit
planning and zoning ordinances that
prohibit short-term rentals
uh representative Tripp is there a
motion uh Mr chair I move not
recommended for rec for uh legislation
's been made and seconded uh any
discussion
being none uh take the roll call please
SB 249 not recommend Vice gem piamati
yes collect folks yes representative
Tripp
yes representative Guffey yeah
representative lasalles yes
representative Platt yes representative
Melvin yes representative Smith yes
representative power yes representative
majority yes
representative Gilman yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative yes
representative van yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative run yes
and chairman Dolan yes
motion pass is 17-0
great thank you those are the six bills
that we were charged with uh
with today
um
before before we leave before we adjourn
I'd like to make sure that we have the
reports lined up to be written these
reports yes you have a question
I have a process question Mr chair
um presumably a report would be written
on the outcome of an interim study
we have had no interim study on any of
these bills
despite the fact that we in the minority
volunteered for interim study and wanted
to to do that and the legislature voted
to refer them for interim study what are
we writing a report on doesn't the
report that's already been written stand
if there has been no interim study
conducted the the report is different
than the uh normal uh
reports that we write uh that are that
is more or less
uh caucus
uh intentional that this these these
reports are more and bipartisan written
as as to the fact that uh whether an
interim interim study was done and
whether or not it's recommended for a
future legislation and and uh or not but
an interim study was never done right
and so that would be part of the report
but the bill we have just voted on the
bills as they stood because no study was
conducted right and now now you were
voting on the last six votes were
whether or not
there should be continued legislation
for this for this isn't that the end of
the story
right why is there a need for a report
to explain to the to the clerk and to
the rest of the uh the legislature as
what we did with these bills and why we
did it
there was no discussion as to why we did
what we did it was simply a state from
from you at the opening of the meeting
that we were not to discuss the merits
of the bills or amend them we were only
to vote on whether to refer them for
future legislation or let them die a
dignified death
there was no discussion to report on
yeah I I understand how you feel anyone
else have any comments on along those
lines
yes sir over there in Melville oh I'm
sorry representative
thank you Mr chair I echo my colleague
representative stavis and it just seems
um
what am I reporting on there's you know
it was a study imagined Phantom study
that showed the outcome of this Phantom
study was a bipartisan recommendation
now to send it forward or not when there
was no
study
and so it just seems very
ingenuous in the process of legislative
process so
I think it you know there's really no
merit to what we write
and um
I'm just not comfortable
okay well I appreciate your comments Mr
Smith
thank you Mr chair I agree that this is
kind of a
an odd process because even if you do
recommend them for future legislation
the Bill's still dead this is the end of
the process it doesn't matter excuse me
what you recommend
but we do have to close the file on the
bill this is just a pro forma thing but
I would like to ask the chair
when you exec these and they went on the
house calendar as interim study and in
those committee reports that the house
voted on there were concerns or
questions within that report how many
Bill sponsors provided you answers to
those questions and then requested that
you hold a work session there was no
further input Beyond
the uh the uh a vote that we took uh in
executive sessions thank you Mr chair I
know that if you had interim studied one
of my bills I would have read the
committee's concerns I would have found
a way to address those and once I had
that material for you then requested
that you hold a work session
thank you
probably a good lesson learned for the
committee that if uh if that's the
intent of individual legislators then
that might be a recipe that we follow in
the future
um yes Representatives so is the
intimation here that if a Bill's sponsor
does not request any further information
from a committee
where the bill is referred for interim
study that there is no need for interim
study is that is that I think it's none
not the need it's the Assumption if if
there is no additional queries or
requests for information then the
assumption is that uh there's there is
no interest in uh continuing it I I
would think that our voters might differ
I think our voters might want us to be
doing what they sent us here to do which
is to conduct interim studies on bills
that were voted for interim study
regardless of what the sponsor says
the legislature voted these for interim
study not the individual sponsors
yes representative Smith did you have
something to ask
I'm sorry
okay I'll get you
go ahead thank you Mr chair not sure why
we're having this conversation you're
debating a house process which is a
thing that you would take up and rules
or what the speaker's office the U.S
chair of the committee have no control
over how this works and as a side note
when we train new legislators too we
tell them that it isn't the committee's
job to fix your bill so I'm gonna stand
by what I said that if you didn't pass
my bill I would and I cared I would feel
the compulsion to do the work and the
responsibility for that in my 12 years
that's kind of how it's worked
but again if they're upset with the
process that's something to take up when
we vote on house rules or suggest
changes to that because there is nothing
that can be done for the bill today and
one thing we're not supposed to say
publicly there are cases to where
interim study is referred to as death
With Dignity for a bill
so uh there was a good example probably
six years ago I won't say the
representative put the bill in but they
wanted to do something that was nice we
all agreed with it
it was a good thing to do sadly it was
mechanically impossible what they wanted
to do was something the state agency has
no power to do
we didn't want to just itl it and say no
this is not something the legislature
should do that one went to interim study
I talked to the bill sponsor about why
it happened they understood and no work
session was held and the bill was not
recommended for future legislation
so there are some nuances there maybe
people care maybe they don't I don't
know but if you don't like the process I
don't like it either you could just as
easily have not come in today and the
results is the same but we're required
to do this so if you have ideas I know
I'm happy to hear them but this isn't
the form to do that thank you
representative manjapudi
thank you Mr chair
um
I know this is not a debate of uh the
process and stuff but this is I'm
finishing up my fifth term 10 years and
uh to say that once the bill comes to
the committee it's not the individual
sponsors bill it's not my bill or
somebody else who is co-sponsored with
me I was always under you know once the
committee takes over it's the
committee's bill and committee makes the
decision how it's going to go what it's
uh you know and as a collective uh
committee members vote on it and that's
how it stands that's my understanding of
the process and this time it seems like
the whole process is all over the place
so I don't know which way the process is
going so that's my
two cents and
I'm just making a statement thank you
thank you one last comment uh
representative Gallagher and then we're
going to close I'm sorry um then we'll
have representative wrong but so yeah
just
um for the record I do not remember
being told that I need to ask specific
questions after a Bill had been
uh referred to interim study I'm a
freshman representative here and
um if that was in the training or
something I must have missed it so I
really would have been
appreciated if I had been more informed
ahead of time that I needed to
ask specific questions to have as part
of the interim study process okay
representative run last comment thank
you um I think if we have to do a report
on the votes we took today I think we
need to be honest and say there was no
interim study but the committee voted
these recommendations are not
recommendations I don't want to have
those reports reflect that there was
study done when there wasn't study done
I think it needs to be an accurate
reflection of what happened
and to get to representative Smith's
point about death With Dignity I can't
see how any of these bills are more
dignified because we didn't make a
recommendation for them to go through so
as I said during interim study reports
at previous executive Council executive
sessions in the spring
I'm a I'm generally I think I don't
think I voted for any interim study
because it did it it would it requires
representatives to meet over the summer
do study and then come back and that's
an investment when of time and resources
when it was very clear on at least two
of these bills that they were not going
to go anywhere they were uh they they
presented conflicts and existing statute
where the bill did not correct that in
fact we had voted on two of these bills
itl and if you remember the committee
came back the next day to reconsider
that to vote for interim study for what
to waste our time to waste our committee
assistance time the researchers time you
know time is money and we've wasted a
lot of time and money for the New
Hampshire taxpayers by going through
this farce of thinking that we're doing
something dignified when it does not
nothing to me wasting resources is the
most undignified thing we can do and
that's what we've done today thank you
thank you okay
that being the last comment I think that
we I would like to do is look at these
six bills see if there are any
volunteers to help write the reports
and also give a little coaching on what
those reports are to say in terms of uh
again these are not partisan outputs but
they should be
summarized for the clerk uh in such a
way that does not overly slant the uh
the response to be in favor of one side
or the other but just basically an
observation of what we did uh with each
bill
so uh do I have volunteers that want to
uh
participate in the right in the
composition of the reports Mr chair I'd
be happy to assist
um if that's okay with
with the rest of the Dems okay by the
way I want these reports to be submitted
to me before the end of the week for my
review before they're submitted
uh
so uh
I've got one volunteer
any particular report you are interested
in writing about
or don't mean to assign it just the sign
away I'd be happy to help okay
um anybody else uh willing to write
one of these reports yes
I'll do uh 11 55 and 249.
foreign
triple do HB 1155 and SB 249
2170s huh
any anybody else
I'm just giving giving your heart damage
anyone else want to write a report
interesting running report to help Tony
out because Tony has to write all the
rest of them otherwise
yeah he writes a lot of reports
You're Gonna Write the rest sure
okay uh okay without any uh further
comment the the advice share will write
the remainder of the reports
uh what's that
me
I serve at the pleasure of the chair
how about there was no second to that Mr
uh Mr Clark would you like to write uh
Jim would you like to write uh 12 23 and
1289 they're both 17-0 done
okay so we get four
uh all right then we get three
volunteers
for four bills Tony write the last uh
couple all right with that uh
we're gonna end the end of the day any
final comments saying none
session is over thank you for coming in
on this uh
on this Tuesday
and uh watch your calendars for uh when
our next session is going to be uh
probably in November uh
no nothing in November
Pearl Harbor day is the next time we we
get together